en este vídeo veamos la solución de
algunas ecuaciones trigonométricas lo
primero que haremos es que en lugar de
encontrar todas las soluciones sólo
encontraremos las soluciones que estén
dentro de un intervalo de 0 a 2 pi y
bueno como un recordatorio aquí tenemos
una parte del círculo unitario tenemos
los valores pi entre 3 y entre 4 y pi
entre 6 ok entonces encontremos las
soluciones en el primer ejemplo vamos a
resolver 2 coseno de x menos 1 igual a 0
bueno yo lo resuelvo de esta manera si
vemos un coseno elevado a la primera
potencia podemos suponer que sería lo
mismo a que si resolviéramos 2 x 1 igual
a 0 entonces resolver esto es igual a
resolver 2 coseno de x menos 1 y en este
problema simplemente podemos sumar 1 en
ambos lados y dividir entre 2
entonces hagamos lo mismo para el otro
si sumamos 1 en ambos lados de la
ecuación nos queda que 2 por el coseno
de x es igual a 1 y después simplemente
dividimos ambos lados entre 2 y así nos
queda que coseno de x es igual a un
medio ok ahora pensemos en los ángulos
correspondientes del círculo unitario y
recuerden el coste no representa a la
coordenada x entonces vamos a localizar
el primer lugar en el que la coordenada
x es un medio miren el primer lugar en
el que el coseno de x es igual a un
medio es en el ángulo pi entre 3
entonces x es igual a pie entre 3 esa es
una solución y del lado izquierdo del
círculo unitario todas las coordenadas
de x son negativas así que en este caso
no serán una solución pero si reflejamos
el ángulo hacia abajo obtendremos otra
solución que es
5 upi / 3 porque si toda la distancia es
2 pi que sería 6 y entre 3
entonces pi entre 3 reflejado hacia
abajo es el ángulo 5 pi entre 3 estas
son nuestras soluciones hagamos otra uno
un poco más complicado
supongamos que tenemos senos de 2 x
igual a coseno de x bueno un truco para
resolver estos problemas es simplemente
usar las identidades trigonométricas y
miren conocemos una identidad
trigonométricas para el seno de 2x que
dice que es equivalente a 20 de x por el
coseno de x y del lado derecho tenemos
el coseno de x ahora tengan mucho
cuidado muchas personas tienden a
dividir toda la ecuación entre x pero
eso no es correcto porque terminamos
perdiendo soluciones miren
esto es como si resolviéramos la
ecuación x cuadrada igual a x si
dividimos ambos lados entre x nos
quedaría x igual a 1 que sin duda es una
solución de la ecuación x cuadrada igual
a x pero el problema es que 0 también es
una solución y se obtiene al restar x en
ambos lados
después factor izando y finalmente
igualando cada factor a 0 así es cómo
obtenemos 0 y la otra solución que es 1
entonces lo que necesitamos es hacer que
las ecuaciones sean igual a cero y
factorizar las y eso es lo que haremos
aquí
y algo importante si dividimos entre
coseno de x eso sería como dividir entre
0 y perderíamos soluciones entonces si
en su lugar restamos tenemos 2
x por coseno tx - coseno de x igual a 0
y ahora simplemente factor izamos el
coseno y nos queda coseno de x por 20 de
x menos 1 y eso es igual a cero ahora
simplemente supongamos que cada factor
es igual a cero podemos suponer que el
coseno dx es igual a cero o también que
dos seno de x menos uno es igual a cero
y al sumar uno y dividir entre dos nos
queda que el seno de x es igual a un
medio ahora identifiquemos los lugares
del círculo unitario en los que el coche
no es igual a cero miren el coche no es
la coordenada x y el primer lugar en el
que x
es igual a cero espí entre dos y también
es igual a cero en la parte de abajo que
es 3 y entre 2 entonces tenemos y entre
2 y 3 y entre 2 estas son las soluciones
para la primera parte y después para
resolver seno de x igual a un medio
bueno nuevamente pensemos en los ángulos
miren la coordenada que está
representada por el seno y el primer
lugar en el que tenemos un medio es en
pie entre 6 e igualmente del otro lado
tenemos un medio pero ahora
correspondiente al ángulo 5 entre 6
entonces tenemos x igual a pi entre 6 y
5 y en 36 estas serían nuestras
soluciones hagamos otro ahora supongamos
que tenemos dos más el coseno de 2x y
eso es igual a 3 por el coseno de x
en este problema aplicaremos la misma
idea primero tenemos que usar una
identidad trigonométricas para el coseno
de 2x y de hecho hay un par de
identidades que involucran al coseno de
2x en este caso usaremos 2 coseno
cuadrado de x menos 1 y eso sigue siendo
igual a 3 coseno de x ahora observen que
en este problema en realidad tenemos una
ecuación cuadrática que involucra al
coseno entonces si nos deshacemos del
paréntesis y reordenamos las cosas nos
quedan dos coseno al cuadrado de x y más
2 - 1 es más uno y eso es igual a 3
coseno de x si restamos 3 coseno de x en
ambos lados nos queda 2 coseno al
cuadrado de x menos 3 coseno de x más 1
igual a 0 y esto se puede factorizar de
la misma forma en la que
factorizar 2x cuadrada menos 3 x 1
entonces si factor izamos 2 coseno al
cuadrado de x menos 3 coseno de x 1 en
un paréntesis nos queda como 2 coseno de
x y en el otro coseno de x y la única
forma de obtener uno positivo es si
usamos más uno más uno o menos uno menos
uno pero como tenemos este número
negativo en medio entonces escribimos
menos uno y menos uno y ahora hacemos lo
mismo es decir simplemente suponemos que
cada factor es igual a cero entonces
para que el primer factor sea igual a
cero simplemente sumamos uno y dividimos
entre dos y así nos queda coseno de x
igual a un medio y en el otro factor nos
queda coseno de x igual a uno positivo y
ya sabíamos que las soluciones para
coseno de x igual a un medio son
y entre 3 y 5 entre 3 hijos
x igual a 1 lo encontramos en los
ángulos x 0 y 2 pi y recuerden que solo
estamos encontrando soluciones entre 0 y
2 p entonces estas serían nuestras
soluciones hagamos uno más
supongamos que tenemos seno de x igual a
la tangente de x bueno esto lo podemos
reescribir como seno de x igual a seno
de x / coseno de x ok y debemos de tener
mucho cuidado de no dividir ambos lados
entre el seno de x pero lo que sí
podemos hacer es restar seno de x /
coseno de x y eso es igual a 0 y después
simplemente factor izamos seno de x y
nos queda como seno de x por uno menos 1
entre coseno de x igual a cero entonces
si cada factor es igual a cero
tenemos que ser
dx es igual a 0 y en el otro factor es
decir 1 - 1 entre el coseno de x al
sumar 1 entre 1 coseno de x nos queda
uno igual a 1 entre coseno de x y esto
es coseno de x igual a 1 y así es como
encontramos las soluciones entonces seno
de x igual a 0 se encuentra en los
ángulos 0 p2p mientras que al coseno de
x igual a 1
sólo lo encontramos en los ángulos 0 y 2
p así que estas son nuestras soluciones
espero que este vídeo les ayude